Fiat the concern that I have with its
future is that the US government banned
gold ownership for four decades because
of it it being a threat to the US dollar
How concerned are you that if Bitcoin
ever presented a real threat to the US
dollar that it would suffer the same
fate so I think on on in general holding
back Technologies very hard to do um the
United States and China are really the
entities that have a lot of Firepower to
cause Bitcoin um challenges one thing to
keep in mind is that um the gold ban uh
in the FDR days was in an environment of
super political concentration so his
party had like 70% uh of of Congress for
example and so you could you could stack
the courts you could you could override
you could you could just do super
majority stuff um and that's not the
world we have today so I think that
basically yes if we were to have a super
majority of government that does not
like Bitcoin uh that really could set
back Bitcoin for for quite a while uh it
could damage the liquidity of the
network uh it could it could force uh
institutional investors to uh discourage
it it it could render it on to the the
gray Market or black market uh and of
course there still be foreign usage of
it there's plenty of hubs around the
world that would happily say Okay build
your companies here and it's it's free
to use here but it would damage
liquidity but I think that those types
of jonian things are harder to do if
there's not that kind of super majority
concentration of power it's also why I
do think that some political work's
useful I mean I'm not I'm not really
politically engaged but there are other
people that go out and uh you know talk
to senators and congressmen and make
sure they understand it I mean during
this recent uh multi-week period where
there was no speaker of the house the
acting speaker of the house um he he's
hosting the Bitcoin white paper on
congress's website and so the acting
speaker of the house and you know for
now he's he's it's still there he's not
the acting speaker anymore but he's
still you know Congress is hosting the
white paper um and and that's that's the
world we live in where there are
Senators that like it there are Congress
people that like it um there are there
are Governors that like it there are
presidential candidates that like it and
we also have a somewhat independent
Judiciary and rule of law and you can
point to things like the first amendment
the Fourth Amendment and there's context
in that where for example in the 1990s
Phil Zimmerman um got in legal trouble
for introducing open source encryption
to the world and uh the US went after
him but they they eventually lost
because they couldn't get past the the
First Amendment once he published the
code in a book uh and I think that
Bitcoin has similar methods to try to
protect itself from the most Draconian
um push back so what might a transition
to a more bitcoin-based monetary system
look like like what are the main
technical obstacles that need to be
overcome to really get that
that widespread adoption because it
seems like right now what you were
saying is that stable coins are the big
thing that uh people in countries with a
weak currency are adopting a stable coin
just for anyone listening who doesn't
know it's basically a cryptographic
token that is redeemable for a national
currency like a US dollar so in a sense
people are still hungry for US Dollars
what would have to change for that
hunger turn to
bitcoin I think a lot of it is just
liquidity uh and so when Bitcoin traded
,000 a day uh a millionaire couldn't
just go in and put a million dollars
into without moving the price that the
overall liquidity and salability were
low when Bitcoin traded Millions a day
someone couldn't just come and put a
billion into it um without moving the
price and even today when it trades
billions of dollars per day um uh you
know they're very large pools of capital
that that if they're not careful they
could move the price it's just not it's
not a big liquid enough market for them
to really kind of um go in significantly
it's still not doesn't have enough money
properties for them yet it has money
properties at lower levels but the the
bigger you get the less liquid it is and
so it's still a tiny fraction of the
overall dollar monetary system which is
much bigger much more liquid uh much
more entrenched Network effect so I
think that part of it is just going
through a handful of more Cycles I mean
it has the benefit of absolute scarcity
so it's growing at a lower rate uh and
addition developers keep building on top
of it so there's more layers uh to they
can be using it there better wallets
better user experience um part of what
um you know I originally discovered
Bitcoin in like 2010 or so and it's one
of those things where in order to get it
you had to like mine it and then like I
would revisit it a couple years later
like I didn't buy any or didn't didn't
acquire any I and I would kind of look
at the exchanges and they'd be really
sketchy looking and you had to like wire
money to like you know Japan and then
like you it's like this whole thing and
then of course it became much easier to
do it and then the wallet technology
became much easier to use and so part of
it is just the ux gets better over time
liquidity gets better over time and then
of course every year that goes by people
try to find more ways to break it or
centralize it things like that so it's
kind of like it's being tested for its
hardness you know can someone find a way
to you know break the overall technical
capabilities of the Bitcoin Network and
every year that goes by where that
doesn't happen the the Lindy effect on
it is
strengthening um unlike most
technologies that can be adopted very
quickly and smoothly so you know most
Technologies you adopt like the
smartphone you never go back to to not
having a smartphone you don't adopt
electricity and they go back to not
having it a new monetary technolog is
different because unlike those uh it can
be levered uh and so if it starts to go
up in a smooth pattern people will
realize that and leverage it and then
they will make it a bubble and it'll
crash and then people actually deopt it
they'll be like well I I messed up I
shouldn't have bought Bitcoin it's a
scam and they they get out and then
Bitcoin as has been a few years
rebuilding from people that actually you
know deeply followed the the network and
understand what's going on there and say
okay there's a there was a local bubble
and it's going to work itself out and
then they kind of re Rec into the
network on the next cycle so by its very
nature it's going to adopt basically a
cyclical and longer taking way and I
think really starts to challenge dollar
one of two ways either just the sheer
liquidity and size of the network
eventually reduces the volatility of it
you know if it's held by um just you
know bilon people around the world in in
some small way that's less volatile
Network than one where you know some
like guy with crazy hair and the in the
Bahamas can like you know manipulate the
price it just gets harder um and and two
um uh the United States dollar does have
some kind of long-term fiscal challenges
with it now uh that we've not really
seen in a very very long time um and So
eventually the dollar can enter a more
structural infl inflationary uh
problematic period um kind of like what
Japan would look like if Japan had a
trade deficit uh and had these other
kind of challenges and so I do think
that either the dollar can hurt itself
or Bitcoin can just keep Gathering
liquidity and tactical proof and and and
just overall better ux assuming again
that nothing no one finds a way to hack
it centralize it censor it or otherwise
disrupt it hey thanks for watching that
clip from my conversation with Lynn
Alden about her new book broken money
you can watch another clip right here or
the full conversation over here